bringing broadband to rural areas is an
important topic here at the debate in
Warsaw this week and I'm talking to
Richard Jones Richard you're you've been
on a panel talking about rural broadband
what was some of the main debating
points this week I think it's
interesting that it's very difficult we
think about five of being a very
expensive technology to deploy actually
in places like Ireland they're
recognizing the need to get fiber into
these are all areas otherwise you
maintain this digital divide but some of
the ways that that works in some of the
ways that it doesn't it's very easy to
screw up and it's very easy for some
operators to game the system and to try
to maintain their their foothold in some
area so it's a it's a good good chess
game and an adventurer next you've
actually got quite a lot of experience
you you've been around the block a bit
with this give us some of your
experiences I think you're kind of
changing the rules to some extent what
we try very hard to change the rules so
in Ireland we've been working with the
electricity company to use their network
to deliver 50 time across the country in
a man like a mini national broadband
network using the waste water network
using the trenches that have been built
there and a variety other places problem
kazakhstan to curacao trying to make
sure that people aren't just spending
money on infrastructure which doesn't
have a return building the ecosystem
around these networks creating ultra
lean networks where they're our own
network in Sweden had two and a half
thousand subscribers per employee trying
to mirror that across the world do it
right because ok I suppose every country
is different oh there's no you can't cut
and paste if you try that it works Sara
Lee and I think actually you've got a
new venture nope no pun intended there
but you've actually taken gigabit into
Africa we have with taking we were the
number one for open access managing of
networks in Sweden we're taking that
model global our first customer really
proud to say in South Africa and that's
the first we think gigabit service in
Africa and if you can do in South Africa
you can do lots of other places and
we're also talking to lots of other
places about that what were some of the
you know things you had to overcome in
Africa wealth Africa is an interim place
that South Africa in particular because
there's a level of theft of copper
cables which is huge it's an industry
and unfortunately if you put a fiber
cable in the ground nobody realizes it's
fiber so they steal that as well so
there's some minor security things like
that but
a in reality to make it work there you
have to be incredibly lean incredibly
efficient otherwise the business model
won't work and that's luckily something
we're good at from our Swedish
experience which is thanks very much for
talking to us so bringing fiber
internationally is sometimes about
changing the rules